can i ask are you the gentleman and i'm
fairly sure you are that a few years ago
told me that uh you hadn't got a cold
since you started doing fist bumps
instead of handshakes
it that that's probably me yeah is that
yeah i remembered i remember that
several times during covid and being
like he was right
what's really funny is how many people
right before covet happened would talk
to me about how do you get away with
just doing fist bumps and not shaking
hands i go it's real easy i don't give a
[ __ ]
i just do fist bumps you know like
that's it i was ahead of the curve yeah
you weren't dating anyway sorry chad
didn't mean to distract you
so uh sandra the last time i spoke to
you uh you revealed or told me how much
of a true crime buff you are you
recommended a show i forget what it was
but i am curious what have you been
watching recently that you want to
recommend
nothing other than what my kids are
watching just
insane youtubers doing insane things
with food and science and information
like i'm literally down serious rabbit
holes
in that department um i just have not
had the time to do anything
other than that so i haven't been able
to sink my teeth into any show get lost
in anything
um
so just crazy youtubers
that apparently all live down the street
from us my kids are convinced they're
all down the street and i was like honey
they don't live down the street no they
do and i'm like okay
all right
daniel if someone has actually never
seen anything that you've done before
what is the first thing you want them
watching and why
um honestly swiss army man because i i'm
really proud of that film and and it's
just
so bizarre that but i also think it's
one of those films that like if you
showed it to an alien they would like
learn stuff about human beings from it
like it is actually saying something
good about humanity um so yeah i would i
would go for swiss army man uh sandra at
what point in the shoot did you say
what the f was i thinking wearing this
onesie uh as my outfit for this film
you know it wasn't the onesie that sent
me over the edge it was the boots
it was the boots and i was like it's not
gonna be funny if she conveniently is
given a pair of sneakers
you know and then the audience is gonna
look at it and go really sneakers so now
you're conveniently in comfortable shoes
it just didn't make sense and the
directors were like well maybe the heels
i said no it has to be a heel
or it's not funny
and like i was in so much pain the
jumpsuit was a blessing it was the shoes
that killed me like climbing water river
like it just was it was so painful um
that's when i i would i would complain
but i couldn't complain uh audibly
because then the directors would go we
told you we told you and i was like
you don't know comedy like i do
yeah it was the shoes what i really
enjoyed about this movie is it's just a
fun popcorn movie and it has like comedy
and action and like it's just a
feel-good fun movie can you sort of both
talk about that aspect of it yeah i mean
i think there is something lovely about
when you are going to work and you know
the mission you have is to make
something that is essentially joyous and
escapist and fun um you know obviously
there's a there's a place for dark
confrontational cinema but there i also
i think it's a really noble thing to
make something that's just fun and
enjoyable and it makes the
the process of making it is is very
lovely as well so yeah it was it was
very very fun to make a movie like this
yeah it's escapism i mean why why is the
escapism only allowed to be in in a
marvel film you know where you have
these fantastical moments that allow you
to just dream a little bit and not have
the weight on you um
and we had to tick those boxes you know
there are those moments that i'm like i
would love to be a part of a moment like
this but make it better make it more
meaningful make it you know and you you
have a responsibility to the audience to
to give that fantastical um
beautiful
landscape the the moments like when
you're shooting you go you know we can't
shoot this because it doesn't show
enough and so where can we get the scope
and where can you get the feel of being
someplace else so it's there's a lot of
responsibility to it but
when you pull it off and i think we did
it's like you know i keep saying i wish
we were a ride at disneyland i wish our
film could be a ride because it would be
that moment of like i want to go travel
for an hour and 53 minutes
and i want to go where they went one of
the things i liked about this film one
of the many things is that i and i don't
want to get specific but the ending was
not what i expected and i really liked
this ending uh because it was which
which ending
oh um wait did you guys uh where the
treasure uh is not what uh yes
that was really
important when when i got the script the
treasure was a treasure um and i was
like i don't want a treasure like what
everyone is hunting for
goods and value in stuff i'd be really
nice if there was the mythology of
the mythology versus the reality right
of what what was there and
i thought to if this is what people were
protecting
that would be really
meaningful
really meaningful i didn't know that
that had been a change that's great
it's so much more it's also from my
character's point of view it's great for
there to be nothing there that he was
after because it really is it's a sort
of shakespearean reversal
yeah yeah
before i run out of time daniel i have
to ask you i could not be more excited
about the weird owl movie right um could
not be more excited um
i i think it deserves your excitement it
is it is genuinely one of the most fun
things i've ever done what i i
i definitely want to know that was was
it the script that said i want to do
this like can you yeah it really was i
mean though obviously when i was offered
the party i'm a huge fan of al so it was
it was kind of i wanted to do it but
even had the film not been about al and
it was just a parody of this type of
movie about a musician um it would have
functioned just as well like the script
is really really brilliant in and of
itself so yeah i'm excited people say it
uh for both of you um i love learning
about like the behind the scenes of the
making of a movie or a show so for soon
to be fans of this uh what do you think
would surprise people to learn about the
actual making of the movie
surprise how how much we had to cram
into a short period of time the
explosion there's a wheelbarrow moment
that was one take
everything lined up on that moment every
reaction that you see
is genuine because we thought our heads
were coming off watching it with that in
mind your reaction is really scared
scared the crap i didn't poor brad had
to like
take my weight with that wheelbarrow and
jenny was just holding onto my foot
um
and all those things had to come
together and it all happened in one take
and no no actors were harmed in the
making of that moment
i was gonna say on that note i gotta
stop i'm just gonna say again thank you
for your work and uh i hope it's a huge
hit
you